hey guys if you're enjoying the tips and  tactics and how-to on this channel or in  the podcast the Tim Ferriss show I made  this for you try the mentors short  advice from the best in the world this  is the book that I wanted to read so I  went out and I put it together created a  dream list 130 of the best at what they  do people who are icons legends and  asked them all the same questions these  are people in some cases I wanted to  reach out to my whole life ranges from  many many billionaires cofounders of  every company imaginable elite athletes  ranging from surfing to tennis to  powerlifting everything else country  stars actors directors and you can spot  the pattern so some of my friends have  said this is the easiest to read most  useful book that I've put together yet  so checking out tribal mentors calm you  can find sample chapters the whole list  of mentors everything tribal mentors  calm